what entrepreneurship industry actors
mainly do
is to increase confidence maybe the way
to say it is that it's building up
confidence more than it's building up
competence
success in entrepreneurship is just
incredibly unlikely it is rare
right that is one thing that we know for
like a real fact
in social science it's really rare maybe
we should start
thinking about entrepreneurship as
something we engage in through critical
experiments where we try to
disprove our idea right instead of
saying
let me take this idea and see if i can
make it work you should do experiments
and sort of prove out that the idea does
not work
and if it turns out the idea does not
work you should get out of here
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla today we are talking to
someone i've been kind of a fan of his
work for a long time but
um finally i get to sit down and talk
with him this is dr hartman of the
copenhagen business school he is a
an associate professor and he wrote a
paper
about the um i'm going to totally mess
this up
the vablin vleblinien entrepreneur aka
i just want to say because i want to
call it this during this show the
wantrepreneur
sort of thing um and it's towards an
unentrepreneurial economy the
entrepreneurship industry
and the rise of the bleblinian
entrepreneur
can you summarize that idea for us real
quick because
um i think it's a really interesting
concept yeah
so the um thank you for the introduction
uh stephen by the way um
absolutely thank you and thank you for
the opportunity so so
the blending entrepreneur is a or what's
called the entrepreneur that's fine too
um is is our effort to sort of put a
label
on what i think a lot of people
are are seeing right the fact that there
is
that there are people starting
entrepreneurship not so much with the
intention of actually
becoming innovation-driven entrepreneurs
but
more actually to just sort of engage in
the entrepreneurial lifestyle
and to build up the kind of identity
that comes with that um so basically is
entrepreneurship pursued for identity
purposes
not productive purposes you guys have
all seen this
at your s whether it's your university
uh you've seen it at these you know some
coffee shops it's
it's a lot of times people are pursuing
entrepreneurship just to sort of tell
you that they're
an entrepreneur uh kind of idea like the
whole thing of like
uh you know i'm a ceo well when's your
company start well yesterday
and you're like oh okay uh that's very
interesting
and part of your paper argues you're
trying to
if i understand it right you're trying
to explain
a set of sort of uh problems or or ideas
in the field
one of which is that okay we see that
entrepreneurship leads to all sorts of
good things in the economy but largely
this is driven by
a few companies and then you also see
that oh
well actually the um there's the
sort of the failing entrepreneurs or
people who kind of have undersized
results and there's people like
amazon apple you know all these
companies that are driving the
majority of the u.s economy um you're
saying that it's actually becoming
more prevalent to and uh you're getting
more and more sort of
failing entrepreneurs entering the
ecosystem as proportional to their
like successful counterparts and you're
wondering why and you're sort of saying
there's this industry around
entrepreneurs
is that basically the idea yes and
that's um
and that's causing a particular kind of
entrepreneurial firm
to pop up and the kind of firm that is
causing the pop-up is what we call
the blinding entrepreneurs of
entrepreneurs so so basically it's not
our observation that the quality of
entrepreneurship is falling
that's uh from other work which is
referenced in the paper but basically
finding that
like people tend to think that the us is
incredibly entrepreneurial and that's
actually not the case by international
standards
entrepreneurship is also becoming more
rare in the us
there are fewer and fewer
entrepreneurial companies in the sense
that there are fewer startups
and the quality of those startups is
declining
right um all bad things all bad things
as you say it's true that there are like
entrepreneurial companies
play a potentially very big role in the
economy right there's things that
entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial companies do that
established companies don't do
so economic dynamism is very much
dependent on having
well-functioning entrepreneurship right
but that is that seems to be becoming
more rare
and there are all sorts of explanations
that you could have for that
you might say that um for instance
incumbent market power is increasing
right so google facebook and amazon are
basically buying up
and closing down all the really
potentially promising entrepreneurial
companies before they become big
right that's one vision of it the other
is that there is
that there's just fewer good ideas to go
around right that
the good ideas are getting harder to
find
and you could also say that
entrepreneurship education maybe
is getting worse right so entrepreneurs
are
more poorly prepared more poorly
prepared
for entrepreneurship you might say
something about venture capital not
working very well
all of those arguments are valid and you
know social sciences such that
usually things are really complex and
things interact
and the thing that we're saying with
that paper is that
our ex our understanding of the decline
in entrepreneurial quality
has not taken into account that there
has been this really rapidly growing
and by now quite large entrepreneurship
industry
which are companies that target
entrepreneurs as their consumers right
and purportedly help entrepreneurs to
identify
and develop ideas into uh profitable
profitable businesses let's maybe expand
on the types of
like sort of entrepreneur help that one
might see in this industry
right yes so you can there are different
things right the
you mentioned that people have seen this
at their universities right many
universities now have sort of these
entrepreneurship hubs right that could
be classed as a kind of
entrepreneurship industry this is
something which is marketing to
entrepreneurs
to try to help them there's lots of
there's a lot of academic writing on
this books by academics
books by practitioners like experienced
entrepreneurs who then
give advice there's a lot of sort of um
you would call it back office support
for entrepreneurs right we'll do your
accounting we'll do your legal we'll do
your
admin there are lots of entrepreneurship
conferences
expos um there's lots of um
online media um like shark tank stuff
like that like shark tank on television
um and then there's also like the dutch
type of business magazine right wired
fast company
things like that and basically a heap of
books that you can get off of amazon or
anywhere else that will talk about oh
yeah
tell you about how to become a
successful entrepreneur that's right so
there's a whole sort of um
suite of this that all sorts of that all
sort of
pretend to help entrepreneurs right plus
of course there are college
courses um incubators
accelerators things associated with
venture capital as well
all sorts of um things that are sort of
trying to do this
promoting entrepreneurs helping them
identify opportunities
and then and turning opportunities into
valuable businesses
right and this is why i wanted to talk
to you because i read this paper and i
said
oh my gosh this intersects with a lot of
what i talk about i mean obviously
sometimes i'm talking about
outright scams but a lot of times i'm
talking about
people who are sort of proposing that oh
if you're wanting to
go into facebook ads or
you know making a little amazon store or
do you know starting an idea come to us
we're going to help you if you just pay
some nominal fee and they make
their living by basically taking these
fees so they're basically piggybacking
on the entrepreneurship industry
and saying like we are helping you guys
become
better which is a fascinating and um
take and there could be a role for that
if they are indeed making
entrepreneurs better um but it seems
like there's this
we actually see entrepreneurship quality
as you say declining
and so yeah so
yeah go ahead yeah so i mean i think
it's like in a gold rush
right it's always good to sell shovels
and you need somebody to sell shovels
yeah right you do
um for sure otherwise there will be no
digging the thing about the
entrepreneurship industry i mean there's
we don't know a whole lot about this
from research but what we do know
suggests that
what entrepreneurship industry actors
mainly do
is to increase confidence they increase
people's confidence in their ability to
put
entrepreneurs so they enter right we can
see that if you consume
more goods from the entrepreneurship
industry you tend to
become an entrepreneur at higher rates
right
but the performance of those ventures
that consume the most goods from the
entrepreneurship industry tends to be
lower
wow that is really interesting so you're
getting people who
sort of you're encouraging people to
join
and that's successful they're successful
at that
but it's maybe not so successful
or it's demonstrably not as successful
at getting them to
succeed and in fact maybe it's
encouraging people to go into the
entrepreneurship industry
who maybe should not maybe should not be
going into it
who at least or maybe the way to say it
is that it's building up confidence more
than it's building up competence
that's a great way to say that that
might be a way to say it right and
one thing you talk talk about is like
also
entrepreneurs part of this new thing
is it's not entrepreneurship necessarily
as you know a job as much as it is an
identity and the way you get that
identity is by
buying stuff instead of doing like it
used to
maybe you would think that you'd become
an entrepreneurship by doing but
actually there's
some people are trying to become
entrepreneurs almost by buying
i think that's the um right so a couple
of things uh
going on i think the the fact that we
have
have this um celebration of
entrepreneurs right i mean that i think
that's uncontroversial
that entrepreneurship is one of the most
celebrated things you can probably do
right and entrepreneurs are some of the
most celebrated actors in the economy
that makes it possible to benefit from
entrepreneurship simply by being an
entrepreneur
like with like having a company sort of
get you into
into good company so to speak um
so that it's it's infinitely better to
tell your parents
that you are working on your startup
than it is to have
work as a barista which might actually
pay you more
because the entrepreneurship thing could
actually pay you nothing right
and so that's one thing the other thing
is that
because there is an entrepreneurship
industry that provides
goods and services it becomes possible
to consume those goods and services
to do things that are similar
to what you might call real
entrepreneurs right i said
scare quotes right yeah you can consume
your way into
an entrepreneurial identity because we
have somehow
separated the being an entrepreneur
from the success of the endeavor
right um right and that makes a lot of
sense actually like
that's not unreasonable because right
success in entrepreneurship is just
incredibly unlikely
it is rare right that is one thing that
we know
for like a real fact in social science
it's really rare
and so to say that you can only be an
entrepreneur if you're successful would
make no sense
because then there'd be a huge category
of people who would basically like lack
a category
so so that makes some sense but that at
the same time becomes an excuse for
something which is more insidious
and that is that you can basically be in
this consumption practice
and that can make you an entrepreneur um
and that is useless to the economy i
mean there's nothing useful going on
there other than you're just
spending money on things that aren't
necessarily making you
do anything right because you're just
consu it's just a consumption at that
point
yeah yeah the short answer is that it's
totally unproductive right i mean the
the term the blending entrepreneurship
um some people might have had econ
classes where they've
where they've heard about the veteran
goods which is basically
the technical jargon for luxury goods
things that get
more desirable the more expensive they
get so oysters
champagne cars racehorses
stuff like that right yeah um so there's
a way in which
because people don't use it for the
right nobody really likes oysters
right but people like the social
signaling that eating expensive oysters
can give them
so the fact that this thing is expensive
is part of the value
right the functional value is
unimportant and that's
some of the idea it's a social signaling
that
that is valuable to people it's not the
it's not the value that the company
produces
and that's so interesting because a lot
of what i see
there are valuations for certain uh
courses masterminds um
you know these coaching calls that their
their
their cost seems to have nothing to do
with any kind of
objective objective metric it's like oh
how much is your mastermind i'd believe
them just as much if they said 2500 as
2500 000. um sorry not 2500
250 000. because of the fact and i've
heard both
by the way from different people i was
on a clubhouse room last night where
this hypnotist was telling us that he
charges um
300 000 for coaching and it was just
it's just ridiculous you're just
thinking who would buy this but
what you're saying is that there's a
whole type of person who like
they sort of see oh the more it costs
the more i can signal that i'm the type
of person
who can afford these kind of things
therefore i must sort of
be a big deal in a way that you'd buy a
super expensive
um rolex even if you don't really like
watches because it's more about
signaling that you sort of have
the thing right yes yeah that's where
the value comes from
right and what we're saying is that
there are people who become
entrepreneurs
who might have a sense that they are not
going to be who have a sense that they
might not be
particularly likely to create enormous
value but who will still benefit from
being just in the category
i mean most people know that one does
not just start a biotech company
right but one can be an entrepreneur you
just need basically
a pitch deck and you can kind of say
that you're starting a biotech company
right we saw that with theranose
um we saw somebody just start a biotech
company and
we saw you know the the hype bubble form
around it where people just go oh well
this must be
the next big thing because they're
excited meanwhile all the scientists are
saying there's no way
there's just no way and everybody else
in silicon valley is like
elizabeth holmes you're doing such a
good job
and i and that's we're sort of uh
parodying the idea but
it is true that there is sort of
a an encouragement at all costs
positivity of at all costs of this
um kind of field and like you said
rightfully so sometimes because there's
so much failure that's faced
that's sort of is maybe the initial
impetus but at the end of your
paper you say there might be a good
reason to discourage people out of
entrepreneurship
what did you mean by that um okay so
some of the uncertainty that surrounds
entrepreneurship
you can't get around right it was not
obvious that there was a business to be
built on renting out spare rooms
in your house right and yet airbnb
became a thing
right there there was uncertainty that
you couldn't sort of
reduce without trying so what i would
suggest is that
we start right a lot of the
hoo-ha uh celebration of
entrepreneurship that you also mentioned
um sort of says just go and try it right
so i think as especially as
entrepreneurship educators we should
maybe say you know you really need to
know that there's a downside to this
you really need to know that success is
very unlikely
so we should so in that that alone
should sort of make you say
maybe you shouldn't do it once though i
mean but still people will have ideas
that
it's hard to gauge whether they are
valuable or not and it's hard to gauge
whether people will be capable or
incapable of executing them
right right there are situations where
you won't know and so i think the
approach there is to say okay maybe it's
worth trying but then
set up and this is not my idea this is
from a team out of um
bocconi university in in milan
we're saying maybe we should start
thinking about entrepreneurship is
something we engage in
through critical experiments where we
try to disprove
our idea right instead of saying let me
take this idea and see if i can make it
work
right you should do experiments and sort
of prove out that the idea does not work
and if it turns out the idea does not
work you should get out of it
so sort of flipping the burden of
evidence around instead of saying let me
prove that this is great
right assume that the idea is not good
work as hard as you can
to make it good and then do an
experiment to test out
whether you should just abandon and
here's why that's really important
because one of the things that is the
real challenge of entrepreneurship
is that part of what's lionized is going
through the valley of death
of like this idea is not working right
the problem with that
is you have no idea of whether that
valley of death has any kind of
meaningful issue
for your for your company so you have
people who are sort of
persisting in their failure and going oh
this is what an entrepreneur goes
goes through when maybe they should
persist but
more than likely in a lot of these cases
they should exit once they've like kind
of gotten their
minimal viable product they realize
there's no audience for this uh
no no consumers get out so i do
appreciate you really saying that and
because we want to give people who are
hungry for
you know um they're thinking about
becoming an entrepreneur or whatever the
best tools for
doing that in a way that's meaningful
what i always tell people is
you should know the statistics it
shouldn't discourage you from doing it
but you need to know what the real odds
are now you
let's talk about the cost of
entrepreneurship real quick
yeah i think this is actually
underappreciated um
the fact that that there are so many
costs to entrepreneurship so just sort
of the baseline one right
i hear a lot of students saying it'll be
great for my cv
to be an entrepreneur and i and actually
the evidence is
quite the opposite it's actually not
easier to get a job when you have
entrepreneurial experience it's the
opposite
it's harder right um and there are
lots of reasons for that that have to do
with organizations often
wanting people to be specialized um
right
and i would say also if i was an
organization i probably wouldn't want
somebody who was a specialist
in failing and very comfortable with
failing i want people who
didn't take huge risk right um that's
one part
the other part um is that
people who become entrepreneurs actually
have
lower lifetime earnings than than people
who
who have like steady wage employment you
are blowing
my audience's mind right now by the way
yeah okay so this is
underappreciated fact and the same
actually goes for working in a startup
working in a startup does not lead to
higher
lifetime earnings and stephen i mean we
can put the links to the
to the data for this in the show notes
please let's do that um because that's
actually
um that's actually a real thing right
your earnings are
generally lower whether you are an
entrepreneur or whether you
um whether you just work in a startup
because the big
because by the way i want to be clear
the big
idea is in a lot of these cases is hey
the man the nine to five's holding you
down you need to escape the rat race
by becoming an entrepreneur you need to
escape that live the
lifestyle you are meant for with yachts
champagne
and lamborghinis by going to become an
entrepreneurship and you know what's
going to help you
my whether it be a course or whatever
form of entrepreneur help the
entrepreneur help
and they get people in the people aren't
successful
and either they quit and they go back to
their job just sort of works for the
where
or they just like persist and they keep
beating their head against the same wall
and maybe go buy a bunch of other
products
so i do think this is so important for
people to hear
yeah i mean it's one of these things
right we know that um
not to be like super technical but the
distribution of entrepreneurial outcomes
is such that the average doesn't
actually tell you anything
because all the gains from or not all
the gains but most of the gains are
concentrated in a very few
super winners right and lots of people
who are just
getting zero right the economics of this
are a little bit like professional
sports
or music right there are some people who
take down
take home all the earnings and lots of
people who don't
right so average is not particularly
informative
um yeah if you take the average between
myself and jeff bezos we both have an
income of
you know a billion dollar net worth that
means nothing for me right
and that's that's your point um
very true okay so
there are more costs that i think are
worth mentioning go ahead um
right it was the bad news that's the bad
news before you do good yeah
um also it seemed
it seems to be the case that um
entrepreneurs
take more um anti-depressants and
psychoactive drugs right not in the
illicit sense but
in the i understand clinical like yeah
yeah because
because entrepreneurship is incredibly
stressful right if
you were prone to depression anxiety
things like that
it gets worse and if you weren't prone
there's a good chance that it can push
you
over the edge often the um uncertainty
and insecurity that comes with
being an entrepreneur if you're not
particularly successful and the anxiety
that comes with it if you are
right because you have employees who
you're responsible to it actually takes
quite a
strong toll on people's private lives as
well
so divorce rates are higher for instance
and sort of probably just like
relational strain
all around right and you can see how
this can be sort of compounded when
when we're dealing with not just
failed innovation-driven
entrepreneurship but this sort of
entrepreneur
thing right because there's some sort of
right you can imagine how your partner
who might be supportive of you trying
something and being very sincere about
it might
you know might support you as you're
trying to build something additional not
fail
just not succeeding but if your partner
is seeing through this
right and seeing that this is just
identity work you can imagine how that
strain gets
stronger and you can imagine how once
you start reflecting
once you've had a straight streak of
failure and you see yourself as an
um entrepreneur the psychological trauma
can be sort of
quite a lot stronger and actually some
of the depressing but
interesting commentary on the paper
after it came out
has been from people saying like i
wasn't i was a
blind entrepreneur and it hurt me
right um so some pretty heart-wrenching
essays that i've been reading
on that um guys in the comments please
put if you were a
entrepreneur say ah raise your hand say
i was a entrepreneur
we want to know so go ahead um
so basically those are sort of the big
things right
we'll we'll be testing this out of
course more
empirically over the coming years but
the facts of
of the matter are that entrepreneurship
is a it's not a great profession right
it's it is sort of like
trying to become a rock star um nba
player
right it's very unlikely to succeed lots
of downside risk
yeah and most people ignore the downside
risk because there's this incredible
lionization of the entrepreneurship
life right you've got just the constant
bombardment of successful people
and you almost never hear from the
people who don't succeed
um because they are by definition sort
of excluded out from the success
magazine
and so you think to yourself well wow
look it looks pretty great
looks pretty awesome to be an
entrepreneur and i really appreciate you
saying that also people should go look
up i mean a lot of entrepreneurs
um even people that everyone thinks of
as like the most inspirational like
people think like elon musk the goat you
know all that kind of stuff he's the guy
who's saying hey
unless you like chewing glass maybe
don't be an entrepreneur
i mean like i think he said something
like to that effect like it's really
really really tough
um and he's right about that and even
then right i mean even if you look at
really successful
companies um it becomes quite obvious
that the fact that they were successful
of course it has something to do with
them having some talent
of course but they also got lucky
right uh if you look into the story of
twitch
for instance pretty obvious that
i mean it was not like twitch was meant
to be a great success from day one
yeah it started as justin.tv right yes
i'm interviewing i'm interviewing that
the the founder
soon oh great fabulous do you have
anything
to say no i mean it's just like um
i mean they were obviously able to
recognize an opportunity when it came
yeah but they recognized a lot of
opportunities that weren't really
good opportunities um and i think
you know not like they did great right
um
but they were lucky also to um in some
respects
i think probably he will be the first to
say that i mean enormously because
you had to sort of be the guy catching
the wave of
live streaming sort of and there's no
way he probably fully understood what
that meant
or could have foreseen some you know
amazon buyout in his uh
future but yeah i think
so that's a really great point is that
of course luck is involved
um and a huge hugely involved let's talk
about
like one final thing honestly i love
this i love it okay so one final thing
right is that um people think that young
people are good entrepreneurs
actually uh and that's blatantly not
true
actually i just want to sort of insert
that because now we were talking about
twitch and
um you were mentioning some like elon
musk and these all were successful when
they were young right and
a lot of the the cast of characters are
the same right mark zuckerberg
was very young dropped out of school
actually there's really good evidence to
suggest that the most successful
founders are um in their 40s
you're right 45 seems to be the good age
to do it and that makes a lot of sense
right
it does basically the because that's the
point where you actually have some
experience
right you actually know what it's like
to work in a company you might have
managerial experience
you might know an industry that you're
entering there's sort of this
hype around young people being
successful and that
sometimes you'll hear people saying oh
you don't need industry experience to
succeed in an industry it's actually an
asset to not know anything
but it's actually good evidence also on
this that if you enter an industry with
no experience
as an entrepreneur your chances of
succeeding are very low
yeah of course right of course of course
right of course
and the way to think about it probably
is that the people who
become successful when they're really
young would probably
also have been successful when they were
older right so the fact that they become
successful at young age is because
they're just incredibly talented
and lucky right they would have been
successful at other points in time too
most of us need some time to get going
to know what we're doing right i think
that's so
unbelievably important to mention is
that
first of all it makes so much sense i'm
glad you're just giving us the data
on you know success success and
entrepreneurship because i think there
is a huge misunderstanding and i've
had this in my mind i don't think i
formally held it but it's sort of
mythologized in our culture to where a
lot of people feel this way even if they
don't consciously hold this that
yeah young people are entrepreneurs
that's what you do like if you want to
be an entrepreneur you start young right
you get the
you get the failures out of the way i've
definitely probably internalized that
um and there is an idea too that you
don't need
domain expertise this um
is a big idea that you can just sort of
be elizabeth holmes and you can just
walk into
blood technology and you can just
innovate because that's what silicon
valley does
um explain to us
why we need domain expertise i mean i
get that it's a bit
obvious but maybe we should just you
should just explain
well i mean um again it depends on the
industry right but i mean very often
being able to even understand the
technology in a given field
right will will be very important
understanding the business models that
underpin a given field
is going to be very important very often
uh being able to
understand the right people to hire will
often be very important and be able to
engage in the networks
and in the industry culture will often
be very important as well right i mean
you're trying to compete for the same
customers right
so having industry experience will often
let you understand
the customers that you're going to be
dealing with right or very often we find
that people
right they've worked in a given industry
construction for instance and then they
develop an innovation that they're going
to sell to construction companies
right because doing their work they
identify a problem and they come up with
a solution for it that they then sell to
their own company
and and companies like it right so
industry experience is going to
let you know what are actually the
problems in an industry and all of that
is going to be generated and it's going
to help you
not just get good ideas it's also going
to help you sort bad ideas from good
ideas
so finding out what are the low value
things is things that are never going to
fly
so what you're telling people is it can
help to get that industry experience
first because you're now making money
instead of just like floating and
probably losing money
you can do that you can gain industry
experience you can identify a need you
can gain that domain
expertise you identify need once you
have that domain expertise
and then you launch a
company later in your life when you're
actually more likely to succeed
due to your now you have experience
plus at that point you will maybe um be
in a different place financially
yes which can also be very important
like one of the things that i find
um really depressing is that venture
capital will often say that before you
ask for venture capital you should do a
friends and family round
right which basically means you should
ask your parents for money or your
friends
right it's a very nice way of saying
when when
when you're young you're going to be
asking your parents for money
right and sometimes parents will do that
right
but often like if you're not coming out
of very wealthy family
they will be giving you their life
earnings right for your idea
and you can easily imagine how that
really is going to strain relationships
if you don't succeed right there's a
real social downside to that
and the fact is if you wait until later
chances are that you will have friends
who
friends who actually have money right
and who understand the industry and can
help you
not just with money but also with other
things it also pains me when people like
borrow against their house or something
like that right to persist in adventure
it's very painful right as sort of a
precautionary principle i would
if you know that entrepreneurship is
really risky right you should think
about it like buying lottery tickets you
should only bet with house money
so to speak you should only pay with
money that you can avoid to that you can
that you don't mind losing yeah and you
should definitely set hard stops
for yourself um
this is digging yeah yeah you can keep
digging and keep
squeezing out more right and and but if
you know
that entrepreneur entrepreneurial
success is really unlikely you wouldn't
do that
you'd be if you knew that success was
rare you would treat it and if you knew
that it was like
essentially buying a lottery ticket
right you would treat it differently
than if you thought that success was
just around the corner
and so that's one of the things that i
would sort of push people for right
know that it's not very likely to
succeed and treat it as such
let's talk about entrepreneurship advice
there's this huge entrepreneurship
entrepreneur industry which is just like
constantly bombarding people with
entrepreneurship advice the blueprint to
success
as it were uh that's this words i hear a
lot i'm sure that's not
an academic uh term the blueprint for
success but uh
it does happen all the time now one
thing that drives me crazy to no end
is that a lot of these things can be
true but sort of not helpful or
um like sometimes true but not always
true
how do you under very specific
circumstances right
how do you see entrepreneurship
advice helping and hurting people um
with regards to this sort of
entrepreneur identity that people are
cultivating
um okay so in a couple of different ways
right i think it's worth
just sort of underscoring that point
right that a lot of the
advice you get seems really sensible
sometimes counterintuitive
but sensible sometimes right let's give
some of that advice yeah so for instance
you should really get comfortable with
failure
right that's like very generic right um
yeah
something surrounding like the minimal
viable product for instance right you
should
this idea that you should just like try
to get something together put it in
front of customers
accept that it's not very good and try
to learn from the experience
right um other advice like
just pitch pitch pitch right just don't
take no for an answer
try your idea with many many investors
if they don't give you money
keep going um now all those things
i think can seem reasonable right and it
seems to be the case that successful
you can find successful companies that
have done that right you can also find
lots of successful companies that didn't
do that you can find successful
companies that did do it but that wasn't
the reason that they succeeded you can
find lots of unsuccessful companies that
did it
right that did something similar so if
you take something like
um the minimal bible product right
there's a way in which telling people
just like try to get some together
put it in front of customers if they
don't like it
right i mean i think it's the um reid
hoffman of linkedin has this idea that
if you're not ashamed of the first
version of your product you're doing it
wrong
i think it's important to keep in mind
that failure is never good
sometimes you need to build up a certain
tolerance for failure to take risk
right but failure is never good it's
it's
we should say just to be clear it's not
good in of itself
i mean i think a lot of times it's
lionized because the examples people are
using are
successes that are failures that led to
future successes
but people can conflate that with like
oh it means that when i'm failing
this is like a sign of my success and
i'm doing something right
right um that's one thing the other
thing is um
like the pitch to investors right and
keep pitching if they
don't accept your idea right well you
know
there's a way to think about getting
rejected by investors which is that
maybe your idea is just bad right maybe
maybe that is
experience and good judgment telling you
that this is not the way to go
right and maybe persisting
right there are companies that persist
and succeed but there are also lots of
companies
that persist and don't succeed i think
that's sort of important
to keep in mind that you sometimes you
need to take no for an answer
because it's because that is information
that you're doing something wrong
i think generally like the whole
normalization of failure
it's actually part of why you can keep
people in ventures that are not doing
well
right saying that failure is part of the
recipe
and they just need to wait that success
is around the corner i think that is
it's a really counterintuitive way for
most people to think and it's
good that it's counterintuitive you
should be more sort of concise about
what you mean
when you say that failure is good yeah i
think um
the the tricky thing is is that for some
people that really is how they succeed
is they just keep failing and they get
they sort of accumulate experience
through failure
and i think that's the that's the kind
of meaning behind when people say this
but what you're saying is yes but there
are a lot of people who take that
advice which might be good in a corner
case or in a case of you know
this person over here for reed hoffman
it might be good with his
minimum viable embarrassing product but
it could be really bad
for a lot of other entrepreneurs and you
should be smart about
taking that advice or sort of like
holding it very loosely
that type of advice yes you should
definitely you should definitely
think about how how far am i willing to
go and i think you should commit to that
for the fact this is the amount of time
that i will spend
trying to get this to work because
people are going to have different
um circumstances that allow them to take
more or less risk and it's easy to sort
of get pulled in this is
what economists sometimes call the sunk
cost fallacy
right or if i spent a year on it i might
as well spend another month
right um and i think that's definitely
worth considering
and i mean some of the advice is much
more technically we call it contingent
than than it's given credit for right
might work but it might also just not
work at all
and and being smart about when that
advice
is going to apply is very difficult and
i think and and the basic problem is
this i think
people pursue right people go to ask for
advice because they don't know what to
do
right so they have a very dif so if you
knew how to gauge the value of the
advice you wouldn't be asking the advice
very often
so by definition when you get the advice
you are sort of hard to know
it's very hard to know if it's good
advice when you get it because if you
knew whether it was good advice
you wouldn't need good advice that's
hilarious so i think it's
very worthwhile to sort of trying to
separate yourself right the basic thing
that you should probably do
i think is to say how much time and how
much money am i willing to invest in
this
correct and commit to that right and say
it might be that success is just around
the corner
but i don't know if i can wait that long
right that's one thing and then the
other thing is to
definitely do some work to separate
oneself from the hype
to say okay it i don't care if it worked
for facebook
or linkedin or whatever what are the
chances that this might work for me
and then treat your ideas something that
you're trying to prove out that it won't
work
so that you can get out right prove out
that this is too good of an opportunity
to to not abandon right right i think
that's the way you think about it
and don't be afraid to pick up some
industry experience
uh before you jump into your you know
your big idea
i know every idea seems like it's
pressing and it has to be done right now
but i think you made a really compelling
argument
to maybe hold off a bit get some get
some real world experience before you go
launch um your entrepreneurship career
and i mean like not every idea is worth
dropping out of school for
right and there's a big difference
between dropping out of school because
you think it's too easy
right if you're mark zuckerberg and
leaving harvard because you think it's
too easy
that's very different from dropping out
of um pretty much any other school
because
it's not quite relevant yeah that's very
different
and that's a very different sort of
information you're getting
about your potential and to be very
clear
no no absolutely and to be super clear
you can look at the outcomes
of people with um degrees
and especially like iv educated degrees
and you can look at the difference
between that and people who
have dropped out uh on the list of
billionaires mo 30 like 30 millionaires
and
up it is just overwhelmingly dominated
by people who have uh you know sunk a
bunch of time
into their education regardless of
whether you think education's overpriced
or not
um yes it probably is but it's also
underutilized i think if you sort of
have the willingness and the drive
to become an entrepreneur and to work as
hard as some people are for that
i think there's a way to get much more
out of college than most people do
but that's a separate discussion but
sure i think that's interesting
underutilized prop probably you mean in
the sense of
how you're using the resource right how
are you using the access to people who
know something how you're
using the access to networks how you're
using the access to
information i mean because there's no
shortage of people going to college and
you know um but and just kind of
benefiting as much as they could
yes yes not bringing as much attention
you know what i think
there needs to be a paper about the
veblenia
veblenian
college student because there's
certainly like an identity class of like
oh i'm just you know going to school uh
that's a
separate discussion for a separate time
but um but
absolutely yeah yeah so one of the
things you
shot an email about is alternative
strategies
for people you talked about joshua gans
we talked about that yet at mit
uh we have it joshua ganz is at toronto
um
and uh and has done some interesting
work with um
with scott stern at mit and they
basically have a whole series of
papers about you can actually get the
book for free it's online if you search
for entrepreneurial strategy
um you will be taken to the website and
you get the book for free it's
um it's a really good book highly
recommended one of the
reasons i mentioned that uh in our pre
pre-discussion was that you know people
sometimes have the impression that
disruption is the way to be an
entrepreneur right disruption is one of
these things
right you should really go after
challenging industries
upsetting the incumbents things like
that um
i recommend that book because it's so
helpful for thinking about
different strategies and often less
risky strategies to pursue with ideas
right there are going to be cases where
disruption is probably the right path
for an entrepreneur to take but there
are often alternative strategies that
are worth considering and testing out
that will um like disruption is probably
like the most risky
thing you could do right right you're
trying to change
uh you're trying to fundamentally change
an industry
unseat incumbents um and like
established firms like trying to take
down blockbuster
ford whichever like name your industry
incumbent right
and very often that is going to be a
an incredibly risky strategy for all
kinds of obvious reasons their work is
interesting i think because it can
probably help people think about
the value of doing some things that are
less risky but
nonetheless that are going to be
lucrative and interesting for many
people especially if you have industry
experience they're going to there are
ways to think about any given idea in
more or less risky ways
do you think there's a the reason that
we only think
largely of you know um
i guess being an entrepreneur in terms
of disruption because of the fact
that all of the cases that a lot of
people immediately think of when they
think of like
entrepreneur they think of recent
examples
where you had this emerging technology
that really
changed everything and it made
disruption very easily possible for
you know some industries and so you had
these like
monsters come out like facebook tesla
all these companies which it's like
so we always think of those because
those are the most you know the biggest
examples
but maybe the most common example the
examples that actually are bearing out
for a lot of people
are not the disruptive cases and that's
maybe what you're saying
exactly the thing like lots of people
will
or lots of entrepreneurial companies
will be faced with the choice of whether
to do something that is disruptive and
high risk
or maybe something that is not quite as
disruptive more
oriented towards what their book calls
value chain
strategies we're basically trying to
help other companies
do well and succeed right that often is
something that works best if you
actually have industry experience
as we talked about before because you
know the organization's in an industry
and you can say what are the pain points
and how can i sort of try to solve those
in an interesting way so i'd highly
recommend that for most people
sort of just broaden if you want to be
an entrepreneur
if you if that is for you right and if
you're comfortable with all the risk and
all the downsides that we've talked
about
right i definitely encourage people to
read that as sort of a way to
broaden their imagination about how you
can be an entrepreneur
because there are many many more ways to
do it and the silicon valley model is
just one
and it's not going to be the right one
for lots of people it's definitely a
very risky one
i think that's so important and one
thing i want to remind the audience of
is that neither myself nor dr hartman
are against entrepreneurs
um no no quite the contrary
this is about getting people to have
better outcomes by thinking more
critically
about being an entrepreneur what that
means because what
your your paper kind of compellingly
crafts a narrative for is
that there's sort of a um there's an
entrepreneur ideology that sort of a lot
of people just sort of buy into
just like the disruptive idea that
everyone just sort of thinks oh that's
the way you start a company
and of course it's just one of the many
ways you could start a company
um there are a lot of useful ways to
thinking about entrepreneurship
that if you're going into it it is
important to know you have to not just
think
you know only positive thoughts all the
time you have to know the risks
uh part of being a successful
entrepreneur is understanding and
hedging
against risk it is so under um
valued sorry i don't just got a little
uh
that is um excellent summary um
i think the and i think that's
definitely very important right to
really appreciate
is this for me right like we we talked
about this that there is
being an entrepreneur has something of
trying to be a
professional athlete about it right
right
if so that for most people should be a
red flag saying no i'm not going to do
that
if you are called to do it right
then you should definitely know the ins
and outs of it you should
think about the different ways that you
can approach this you should know about
the kind of things that are really risky
and the kinds of things that will get
you injured and the things that will
push you out of the game right yeah and
that will lead you to costs that you
don't want to bear
i think that's really important um
because as you say
entrepreneurship is super important but
well-functioning entrepreneurship is
even more important
like the economy does not work without
entrepreneurship we tried
economies without entrepreneurship it
was called the soviet union and it
wasn't great
right so we need entrepreneurship
a lot but we also need it to work well
and we need people to not be
misled about what it is and the kinds of
risks that are involved
for sure and the realities of how to do
better
at entrepreneurship i mean i think the
funny thing is is you're presenting us
with sort of like
hard data on what so many other people
are promising to make you a better
entrepreneur and you're telling us
what entrepreneurship success looks like
in the data
um and i think that's so important for
people
who are you know in the audience who are
interested in that
um to really take to heart so i will
link we will talk about
uh a lot of the papers and the sources
you cited for statistics
related to success you know when you're
young or when you're
old we'll talk about um you know
education we'll have the educational
strategy book
linked in the show notes and um also of
course i will be linking the paper
which i found i was such a i have cited
that paper a bunch of times sort of
informally on the channel and i knew i
always wanted to do
an interview about it because it's um it
holds a near and dear place to my heart
but let's be clear this is a um
this is a theory right like this is part
of
academia is that you are proposing a
theory to
fit data that you know is happening
which is like declining entrepreneur
outcomes
um would you like to talk about that a
bit a little bit like
hedge a little bit what we're talking
right
so so i think people should read the
paper
um actually because what we're doing is
we're proposing
a way that things might work right and
there are different
interpretations that one could make what
we're suggesting is essentially a
hypothesis
right academic uh production is such
that you often have what's called a
conceptual paper which lays out an idea
and then you have um empirical studies
that do that basically present data
right and we're in the process of
beginning those um
the data collection and but i'm
producing different hypothesis
hypothesis papers um and this is one
right
um the paper that you can find online
now is not published yet so it hasn't
been through peer review the
peer-reviewed version will be out
by summer it has been accepted for um
for a journal which is called this
research in the sociology of
organizations but that will come out and
when you say a lot of
when when you talk about hard data i
should say this is not data that we have
collected this is data from other
studies
um just sort of to be clear yeah
absolutely and the interpretation that
we're offering is
is also not a um is not proven out by
data and it's not
a widely accepted view right i mean
there's quite a lot of consensus that
uh entrepreneurial quality is declining
it's not a
unanimously helped you but it's pretty
close um
so that is a that is sort of a real
thing
the idea that the linking of the
entrepreneurship ideology to the
entrepreneurship industry to declining
entrepreneurial quality is
sort of um that's that's theoretical
right that's our idea and it's
conjecture i think yeah yeah
right so just to be clear oh no no i i
appreciate it i appreciate um
how careful you are and i think that's
an important part of any kind of um
you know if if you're gonna be in
academia that's that's part of your job
right
um is to tell people like what's settled
um
what's not and i appreciate you doing
that dr hartman thank you so much
for coming on the show i hope people got
uh a lot of
to use a loaded expression of value out
of out of that
i hope so too episode so i hope some
more informed career choices will ensue
for sure same here thank you so much
thank you for the opportunity
um have a great day we'll see you next
time
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee